this is blitz bounty live here for the
first time on come on Dennis what are
you waiting why you'll take that ball
illegal both ninety-two honey was
resigning may give me hey Dennis house
gone is your shirt like soaked with
tears is not going too well Caleb I took
your advice the other week to play blitz
bounty okay get some kid loss yeah I
mean sounds like a fun time uh so as you
see my match though this is cool yeah so
I actually beat Jonathan really easily
the easiest match of my life miss fun
homefront like a hundred viewers I
should try it sometime Oh
congratulations I guess I'm really happy
for you I suppose success is something
I'm only ever going to know vicariously
yeah well I mean success is all I've
ever really known carts are me to kinda
relate to what you're going but aren't
you set up another match for you anyways
should we find the ABS so a blitz bounty
round two Michael pugachev coming up
this June you're putting 36 bucks on the
line into Powerball tickets maybe
they'll have a lot of money but hey wait
I don't really want to do this
you